that's where i was born and i think it
was called puta memorial back then
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god
omg omg hi oh my god
you know when your wife likes somebody
when they say i feel like i already know
you
that's a good question a smile on their
face moving towards you instead of going
i feel like i already know them and they
haven't moved at all
don't come and say hello i feel like i
already know them
they don't want to make a move then you
know that they're not that excited
that's funny but yeah i know he called
me when we were in the middle of
playoffs
i stepped off the side he goes can you
get a hold of george i
we got this part for him i think he yeah
i think he'd be great for it i said hang
on let me call him
and it worked out but that guy that
director this this african-american dude
the young guy
ryan i don't know his last name but he's
one of those dudes man like i think he's
going to be a big
director like he's from music and he's
directing then he
used like you know i had to think about
how to walk into this church
and then he hit some music like bill
withers but like a rap
jazzy bill withers it changed my walk
wow
i was to walk in all dark you know and
then you just start walking and he goes
over here the bad people are on this
side just look at him and kind of you
know and then just go up to the thing
but with no music nothing with music and
that church
all changed everything locked in
character okay so
very cool talking about your son's
playing baseball right your son is
yeah julian good old julian bryan is uh
he's 13. he got one more year in little
league and he's going to do uh
play some travel ball this year at bts
yeah chatsworth he's really
you know what's fun this year it's great
because he's really getting into the
game for the first time
he's enjoying it he's enjoying he's a
big dodger fan
is there any other yeah right exactly
so so um
let me ask you guys what you think
because you have grandkids you have kids
my daughter
played a little baseball but didn't so
in coronado high school in san diego
orange glen high school do you hear
about that yeah tortilla no i didn't
so the students and the coaching staff
after winning the cif basketball
championship the
alleged coach of the coronado basketball
team and cor
encouraged them to do their best
which was a little scuffle between the
two sides
and orange glen high school was located
in hispanic community
and then they were throwing
tortillas man oh [ __ ] wait a minute
about this
to the other players to the latino
players on the on the team
i did briefly read this yesterday that's
right so
what so so so cnn called they emailed me
to
to to you know see if i wanted to go on
and talk about it but
i was like why don't you why don't you
call the parents or the teachers from
that school or the coaches sure and talk
to them what [ __ ]
talk to me yeah now i can't do anything
and just like there's a latino guy in
new york
this fool right here that says how come
john leguizamo and george lopez don't
talk about
a shooting in new york like they talk
about other things
like i mean you can but
what do what do we do you know i had a
student when i was teaching the college
level he was from the south
uh african-american guy and he told me
something i put in my in my uh
phone and i've never changed it you know
he said
my daddy used to say some things just
need a whole lot of leave alone
and so in the case of you and
that was almost why don't you say
something about this some things just
need a whole lot of leave alone why
perpetuate the problem that's going on
why give it more attention
i mean we're we're not we're not law
we're not law enforcement we're not
detectives we're people
you know and you know how those
detectives are too yeah
how are
[Laughter]
so i don't know but but
where are we man in this i mean you know
your grandkids your son i mean
yeah i mean it's just
i don't i just feel like they try to
they reach out for representation
because
you happen to be latino or mexicano and
they just assume
but you're right going to the core of
the problem and going to the to the
community and
you know who's gathering tortillas hey
yeah
someone needs to find out where they're
going i wasn't the best athlete i never
even took a [ __ ] chorizo burrito to
the game like i never put it in my bag
where they've been hey what's this they
[ __ ]
[ __ ] throw it out never took it i
left my [ __ ] separate
my cleats my gloves
it all depends you know who put them up
to where they were coming from because i
can go back
to when my kids were in high school and
my daughter was going to be 50 she was a
cheerleader
in high school and i'd go and i'd sit in
the student section
my wife would go sit with the adults you
know the parents i had more fun with the
kids back then
and they were throwing corn tortillas in
but
just to beat ravi it was just like a
frisbee because
they weren't throwing them at at the
mexicans you know because there was a
bunch of latino you know half the
student body there was latino at the
time
it was just a fun thing to do they were
wasting
food but it wasn't racial at all what
happened
uh back there at the basketball
tournament sounds like
and you only know about what the news is
telling you it sounds like it was
racially motivated
and if it was shame on them but that
doesn't reflect on everybody around the
world of the united states it reflects
on that school and those parents
and see that's why i asked him because
me he knows that i'd be the same as you
it sounds better i want you to watch
night soccer netflix day did you go to
vietnam your first day in vietnam
february 1st 1968 come on wow
he remembers all the dates my
grandmother too but not the dates like
if i said hey
grandma can i take some guitar lessons
like the [ __ ] accordion
she came from i don't know what the [ __ ]
every latino kid in separate values
in the early 70s was trying to play the
accordion there wasn't no ramona
no no and even when they played at your
house you just couldn't wait for them to
be
done because you know we spoke english
and they come playing mariachi music and
all your friends are like we're gonna
we'll see you tomorrow
and you grew up in the valley and then
they start playing look at mariachis are
playing then everybody
you know my grandma will pass out or the
[ __ ] paramedics would come and
you think people would leave more people
showed up more people showed up right
[Laughter]
but it's all so and then in
in flying now like and flying i mean
i've been flying these last couple
weekends
if you watch the news people are [ __ ]
losing their minds on planes man on the
southwest this lady
punched the flight attendant like they
they were oh yeah knocked their tooth
out
and fist and people [ __ ] tripping on
planes and a flight attendant that was
just flying
trying to rush the cockpit what's what
is all that about yeah
you know i i have no idea a couple weeks
ago i was flying i went uh
speaking engagement in austin texas and
american airlines it's been on the news
because their their pilots haven't been
coming back to flight crews
bad weather yeah yeah they sold a
thousand flights i went
i was there and you there were
home bases in dallas texas right so
they're
dallas texas and houston had inclement
weather my first flight
got canceled so i was there at the
airport my flight was due to leave at 8
30 in the morning i was there 5 30 in
the morning
and i i got there 10 minutes before i
got there at 5 30 in the morning
i'm in line my flight is cancelled so
it's not a problem we got another flight
you'll make it it's
7 15. plenty of time i said okay you
sure
because i don't want to i don't want to
get jacked over no
so i go in the tsa line well tsa they're
short on people too
it took me so long to get through tsa
and then when i got up to the gate now
they close the gate 15 minutes before
you take off
and they don't open it again yeah i got
there at 703
the gate was closed mother who you are
where you're going
get me on another flight five flights
later
i got home i was due to be back in
ontario at 11 30 in the morning
i landed at 1105 that night and
everybody was pissed off at the airport
everybody you know people are pissed off
this flight they're yelling
uh dogs that are supposed to be service
dogs they're
they're barking they're tired you know
give me some place where i can [ __ ]
you know i want some food anything was
that the people the dogs
both both and and so i just sat back
i would just go sit in the corner and
look at everybody and i'd laugh
it's the first time i i just laugh what
are you gonna do you're not gonna get
that plane here any sooner
listen i don't know if you can get a
like a a superhero costume
that you know that big this dude
and you just go to the airports and you
just make you just squash beef you're
the
beef squasher that
and he just goes in there man like he
already answered the problem
tortillas something a little a lot of
leave alone this dude misses flight he
don't care
he you know he needs to have one just
one suit that they know
they see him why not nothing metal no
pockets
no no pockets just a lot of pokemon you
know one thing he gets
seven twelve they're like come on seven
all right uh that beef squasher come on
get out of here and i feel sorry for
those attendants because everybody's on
there they're already pissed off
and then to top it off as i go to get on
that last flight
one of the guys that works the desk
there and he's helping people he's
checking you in when you get on
yeah and so before you go down that
tunnel he says okay
hey you're that guy from netflix
you're gil creon i said yes he says wow
hey everybody we have a celebrity on the
and so all the attendants want to come
out take pictures
and they took pictures the guy behind me
says can we take a picture i said sure
but you know what
why don't we do it on the inside of the
plane because these people back here
they're pissed off you know they just
want to get out of here yeah there you
go
let's just get it out of the way and
we'll do it in there it's great to get
that but
you know you got to know your you got to
know your crowd i think you leave like a
little like a little sausage like a
little vienna sausage like squashed on
the cherries
that's the mark right there [ __ ] big
squash it was here
but then he figured it out but it's a
pain in the ass and you know just when
you think that people that fly for a
living
used to be like maybe they had a job and
they always want to be a flight
attendant and now they're fine but then
they get to fly
the world and for free and all this yeah
now it's i don't think it's that anymore
i think it's a career and it's a
profession and a lot of those people
that were flying
god bless you for flying because you
know you get a lot of there's not as
many
there's a lot of people that they've
stopped drinking on on the planes like
they stop serving people
yeah yeah they're touching us like
over here except for the first place for
beer
well i just got back from cabo with the
wife and the kids yesterday
from from flying back when i was when i
was texting you don't get any sun
huh i didn't have some blood a little
sun but we almost didn't make the flight
and the thing was because of american
airlines and
they cut down on all the staff that was
there
we go we decided we're gonna go outside
the hotel the day before we go to cabo
wabo
yup to get a thing at tequila for
father's day so i get one uh
my brother-in-law joseph and then he
gets one for me and my wife gets one and
so
we got these tequilas we find out at the
last minute that we have to we got we
can't
we can't ship them out we have to take
them with us and we did carry-ons
so in and out with the kids because we
got i got a jax
is four years old julian's 13 so we got
the kids everywhere so we're in and out
of the airport
so we decided now we got to check in
julian's bag with the tequila stuffed in
there and tell him no there's nothing
in custom no i don't got anything we've
got to fly it over so we go
we get to the airport and
we get to the airport we stuff it in
there and now we're getting ready to
race
i take it back hang on there's there's
there's more to this um
when we left the hotel vanessa loves to
eat oysters she shook that big night she
loves seafood
so we're gonna do oysters and she wants
to do uh
uh basically
they cut a short off of there because of
some weather so she decides they're
going to pick us up at 3 30 and as we're
driving she's going to help
the guy give him 20 bucks stop under a
[ __ ] freeway underpass
on cabo we find a spot 15 minutes we eat
[ __ ] amazing food get back into this
so 15 minutes to eat
under an overpass and cabo amazing food
over here they got letters
a b c d if they had a letter under the
underpass would be like a [ __ ] p
[ __ ] king to keep the wife happy damn
dude eating under an underpass
both kids are in there playing on their
ipads it's all right okay good hurry
we're eating
we get in there and we were supposed to
be there two hours early because we're
an
hour and five minutes late they almost
didn't let us on the [ __ ] plane
and vanessa's begging no please please
please let us on and so
finally they they did get they after
[ __ ]
hardcore conversation with with with my
wife in the uh the attendant they let us
on
and as we're going through security you
know those those [ __ ] license plates
that you get from cabo
so i had gotten a gift from my
brother-in-law and now they're
there we can't take it and i'm just
[ __ ] bonnie
i love joseph and everything but just
you know what let's just leave it we
gotta go
we're gonna they're boarding right now
she [ __ ] grabbed that
thing and joked i won't say uh the hertz
commercial who we were talking about but
she started jumping over
luggage and everything else went
downstairs and they just took it and
checked it in
and we just made the [ __ ] flight
yesterday wow i just made the flight
i was like does it drive you crazier
because i'm not i can't be like my wife
would have driven me crazy that'd have
been my wife i just said get out there
stay with them let's go kids let's go i
couldn't it's just nuts but this is
there's lack of personnel there
and i'd seen them bring those license
plates on board before we've been to
cabo so i didn't get it i was trying to
slip the guy 20 bucks to let us take it
he's like i can't
you got to go check it in she went all
the way downstairs god bless her
just made the flight we just made the
flight and then we got to lax
the [ __ ] belt was was was broken for
we were standing there for 30 minutes
for one checked bag because of tequila
because we always do carry-ons you're
the same way
you don't have to yeah it's easy just to
do the carry-on right the [ __ ] out
all right well what a day okay it worked
out i don't know anybody that works at
what's the number again a18 what
533 1843 818 533
1843 [ __ ] numbers 533 1843 so if you
work for an airline company
wherever you are wherever people are
listening to this podcast because people
are listening
and i think it's because the girl is not
because of me yeah this goes to the beef
squash
the beef so if you if you work for an
airline you don't have to say your name
give us some details behind the scenes
of what's really going on
because they've canceled yesterday i was
in chicago and they canceled a thousand
flights
over the summer so and my heart my hat
goes off to those people because all
they do
is listen to people complain yeah and
justifiably complaining
but there is nothing happy about what's
going on over there so it's a
it's a category well you know what's got
your man like you always have a window
seat and and this morning when we left
from chicago you know the guy with the
flashlights
the flashlights were off because they're
trying to save batteries
[Laughter]
so so ben bray hernandez
is from i'm from actually born born in
san fran
in san fernando uh was in the chaperone
general in san bruno hospital
uh actually i was uh born in panorama
city born in like the kaiser hospital
city and we grew up in van nuys
in the san fernando area same as you
sorry so i grew up in the
border in uh general hospital the lady i
think there was a woman's hospital there
it's a parking lot now i think about the
parking lot back then
they used to have a place just for the
where for ladies that are
pregnant they used to have a section in
the hospital right there right off of uh
mission right in the corner that's where
that's where i was born and i think it
was called putin memorial back then
p.m p.m eight i think it's still around
the memorial
but i thought i was born in the general
hospital
but then i was born in the in the
auxiliary the woman's hospital
wow because it was i think it was such a
factory that
everything it's almost like you know
there's a ceased candy right there like
on the way to the airport that only one
factory that's where all the candy comes
with i used to work at a gas station my
brother-in-law's gas station right
across the street from the general
hospital really and all these interns
used to come in there with
scrapped by cars you know they were just
trying to get through
yeah uh get through their residency
and everything it was tough it's amazing
that things that we used to revere
doctors and all that [ __ ] other [ __ ]
that people try to cut back on
yeah you know and people go to uh
the dude sean that the guy that does
security comes up to us you know and he
looks at his teeth and he goes
i got these in mexico boss [ __ ] white
dude goes to mexico get some [ __ ]
vietnamese eh
i said have you been in the heat because
i'm about to mouth
that [ __ ] they make those license plates
out there he said that he got him done
under the underpass on the freeway
oysters
so so uh what's great is that you know
gil you know i reached out to gill um
when i saw the netflix thing because
everybody's watching it
it's amazing and i called this partner
and i said you still get a hold of gil
we got a hole we came to see me at the
lab factory
you know friends with him he's been in
here people love this dude man they love
this guy
that was a bomb thank you that was a
that was a great night for my family
they loved it
the fact that they got to go up and meet
you and spend time and you were so
gracious with them
uh and plus that's the boot you were
funny thank you i mean god
bless it was it was a great night i was
laughing i was laughing my ass off
i could hear the uh grandma's grand you
heard him laughing
[Laughter]
that's amazing you deserved well
deserved man i'm just another mexican
there's another
one vietnam dude who came back you're
you're a sheriff and community hero bro
are you kidding me
it's amazing it's a great story nothing
else
uh stands out one of the most important
things out there is i can't
begin to tell you how many people are
writing me saying
you re you represent us we're so proud
we now have a latino
you know and and everybody everybody
knows you it's a different
different type you know from what i've
done because i was a i was a
i was literally i was nobody you know
i'm just a cop i'm just mexican grew up
in the neighborhood
don't say that i mean don't say that
because i think we say that like
obviously
there's a latina that discovered hand
sanitizer do you think everybody knows
her name but [ __ ] kleenex everybody
knows that
yeah exactly there was a lady that that
there was a latina nurse
that invented hand sanitizer and they
would go lupe bring it and she went like
this but it had dried already no no
she really did
but i think she did yeah and her name is
not purell
the guy that invented the caesar salad
right there in tijuana
yeah yes yeah yeah he's a big guy so i
i'm just astounded by how many people
are well they're so gracious to me and
we need
that's a hero on a on a huge level
that's a global i mean
people not only by that by that case and
those things but crime
and crime documentaries and crime
i mean listen they know [ __ ] white
people getting killed those
[ __ ] have dinner
murder [ __ ] theater where they eat
and then they go [ __ ] try to solve a
murderer
you think pakistan cnn would call them
about throwing [ __ ] tortillas or
[ __ ] bologna at each other
so you know what i mean i mean it's like
yeah colonel mustard and the
he said in the back room yeah colonel
musser with a rope in the kitchen
why not he did it that that's all we do
is play games like that but
until you listen people are fascinated
by crime
one of the things that is just gives me
chills
is when richard ramirez was hiding below
in the kitchen on the other side of the
counter waiting for
the girl to look over because kale
okazaki
sake right that's right and
he he was just he was wait he knew she
was going to do it
yeah waiting there for her to look over
so he could see the fear in her
in her eyes i mean it's just
unbelievable
and and it's like i know that you you
always say when i watch the documentary
you're saying like
it's like look i was just a young cop
who was asked to do this but you're put
in a position
that you you you just
used you you came with it you're ready
all right you know you put yourself
you were put in a position where you
were uh uh
you know you applied everything and all
your knowledge and it was just amazing
to watch
thank you i i was uh i was a fortunate
man i got there early i was the youngest
guy there for seven years
and then frank uh salerno who was my
partner who had worked on hillside
strangler
he could add anybody he wanted and he he
chose me to be his partner
yeah uh so i was floating and then you
know why do you think he chose you
what why do you think now that you look
back at it back i think that time you
said you know one week i'm here and then
next week i'm eating
you know that's right i'm eating
something
parmesan i didn't know what this [ __ ]
was
and so uh i think frank you know he says
uh i was young i spoke spanish which is
always
a help up there um and
he thought that i had something well i
had a uh
a decent reputation since i had been
there i turned a couple of cases around
and got some people to come out on baby
cases it was really
so i had a reputation for doing good
work i was young i was enthusiastic
i loved the job and i love people
and you don't have to be big and bad or
anything you know you treat people with
compassion
uh one baby i was so stuck
a lady i was i was convinced in my heart
but not in my mind yet
a lady had killed her own baby and she
was mexican national
so i was a young investigator up there
so the first thing i did is i called the
office and i spoke to a guy named
i said who's the oldest guy up in the
office right there and they said jack
fuglin
and i said let me talk to jack so jack
on
his former partner was my boss my
lieutenant so i said jack i got a
question
i got a i got a lady here jack i believe
she killed her kid
but the last thing i want to do is
admonish her constitutional rights
because if she didn't kill her kid now
that's trauma on top of trauma
i don't want to accuse her if her baby's
already dead she didn't do it
but if i don't do it she did kill her
baby as soon as i walk out
she's heading for south of the border
he said kid you got a tough one he says
you better call your boss
wow so i called up my boss his former
partner
barrett fitzgerald i said fitz i got a
problem he said what is it i ran the
whole thing down to him
he said he called me kit he said well
kitty says that's a tough one you got a
you got a tough one right there he said
when you make your decision call me up
and let me know how it turned out
i think it is that was that was a that
was the advice he gave me wow
so i went back in there thought i'm
going to admonish her
and i got her cup out to killing her kid
wow
and yeah and and i just sat there so i
called him up and i said hey
she copped out he says good job kid i
know you did the right thing
geez you were literally on man that was
it he left it to you
yes wow that was my decision and your
instinct said do it
okay and so and it turned out she had
killed her kid
and and her thea because i had been down
the guy that killed
i mean the baby she killed the father of
that child was somebody i'd gone down to
mexico to bring back as a witness
surviving victim wow and he saw her down
here and he
hit it and then he went back to mexico
when i went down to the village he was
from i mean there was it was poor adobe
huts no roads
and so i went in there got him and
a guy named pedro gonzalez brought him
back to testify
i gave them money i'd give money every
week to be here
pedro was gonna pay he was the next day
he was going to come down and pay a
coyote to get him a crystal come on
take him on a plane so we brought him
back here
the girls thea since then had come back
and she was living with a thea over here
in la puente and the theater was right
there when i
took the lady in i talked to her and i
went and i told ya she's not going home
with you today and she's going to stay
with us for a while
and at the end says he put in i said
well she in spanish you know
she's responsible for the death of the
baby and
she says no i said they made us and so
she
she asked she could talk to her she went
in there talked she said
why in spanish why porque porque lui
siste why'd you do it
and she says no no i just told him that
it's not the truth
and she snapped back and she says yes it
is
carrillo says it is it is wow
wow i had that much faith in me where's
that one at um
that one she's still in custody all
right so we're gonna do we're gonna do
guild
by beep squasher the beef squash hey you
own the rights to your story right
you'd be like yeah why wouldn't i yeah
have you been approached enough about
your about your story
no i i can't believe it people are
people who approached me to write books
you know but i've never they said why
not now number one
i don't want to get anybody in trouble
right not criminal trouble right
but i know i'm saying it right now on
the rig on on the podcast
my wife would be looking i know what
you're talking about right there i know
who you're talking about right there
so i don't want to get anybody in social
social problems i'll say this grantham
yeah blame it we'll say it's grand we'll
bring some years we'll bring the years
up bring one of the gabachos
all right we'll figure it out let's say
you went to a band in high school
when i retired i even bought me a brand
new laptop just for
so i could send that information write a
book
and i gave that i ended up giving that
one to my grandson
you know oh my god maybe i'm just too
lazy i don't have time to sit down and
do it myself so if
you know somebody one day will come up
and say hey
i'll be your ghostwriter i'll write
about what's the number again a one
eight a one eight
uh yeah 533
1843 if you're a book writer and you
want you want a deal
armor contained would be a good one you
did my book
but earlier i was scrambling for words
what to say because i was such i was so
blown away
when i watched and i watched it twice
and
the fact that you seized the moment when
you were asked to be part
of that crew and to solve that crime and
the only thing i kept thinking and i
talked to georgia about this earlier
it's like
it'd be so interesting to follow you
your journey
secondary being the night stalker but
how you became who you became
from from your humble beginnings until
you
got onto the force and how this all
happened and coinciding with your
personal life your family life
and also this because i knew that i
remember
at one time your wife was talking about
like things were
oh yeah they they were it was
i'm married we just celebrated our 50th
anniversary congratulations
thank you but wow uh trust me she's the
glue that has kept everything together
over the years you know
right after the nightstalker case laurel
erickson
and i believe paul scolnick they were
part of
the documentary they took us out for
dinner
oh nice and they took us out for dinner
frank and his wife
my wife and myself we went to the uh
johnny carson show and then we went out
to dinner after that oh wow it was on
that nice
nice and i had stopped drinking entirely
really yeah i because i i was drinking
i don't want to say too much but i was
drinking a lot uh during the night
soccer case you know
so right after the case you stopped i
stopped
right after we uh did it and
i hadn't touched a drop in 30 days
wow and we went out to dinner and
my wife was drinking and laurel was
drinking
they're they're both getting they're
having fun
and laurel is talking about frank you
know how and
he has something to say he says that
when not you know he doesn't he says on
the other hand gil
gil should have been a politician
because he said when he's got nothing to
say he'll tell us
when he's got something to say he'll
tell us what he needs out when he's got
nothing to say
he'll talk to us about anything you want
to talk about except for what we want
but he's a he's a great guy to be around
and pretty soon my wife is
starting to cry and she's saying i'm
gonna chase
this case to changed me i'm a different
man
i won't even have a drink with her and
wow
it's just i'm afraid you know it's
leading to problems
and i said wait a minute stop the
madness laurel i don't want to hear
nightstalker investigator heading for
divorce film at 11.
yeah yeah right pearl you keep our
problems
personal don't talk about them and you
mr waiter don't let give me tequila
on the rocks don't let the ice hit the
bottom of the glass get them rolling you
know
give me a backup yeah and i'll and i'll
drink with you yeah and so
things were kind of rough it was it was
tough because i wasn't around
and i realized it now but
everything's uh together everything's
everything's good and she's the one
uh that has kept everything together
she's fortunately for myself she's
riding this wave
that i'm on because people are
recognizing her and saying what a strong
lady she is
because of the documentary and so it's
all good
that's true i was excited to see her i
mean she's she's great
you see her you're like oh she goes i
feel like i know you i mean you took
some nice pictures
yeah that's really very you know you you
also
i'm not that fortunate uh you know the
women in my life have been
mean to me and
i don't respond well to that and i you
know god bless you and you
and i know you know people that have
somebody that's
really great for them i mean
maybe circumstances in my life the way
that i was raised or you know i didn't
see a lot of healthy relationships that
maybe you know it kind of you go down
that road
in in real life that i mean i don't know
is it too late yes
yeah i thought you wanted to answer that
but i know you you know you and your
and your wife as well you know yeah
she's she's been
amazing i mean it's it ain't easy
marriage is not not easy you know
and it this was for me it's the third
one it took me three times
see anybody who says marriage is easy
has never been married never been
married yeah
tough there you go anybody who says they
slept like a baby
has never had a child right over one eye
open that night hasn't been married
that's right that's right um but yeah
you know it's it's it's uh
for me very similar to george's back and
like you know i didn't have very
positive role models not only my father
was never around
you know my mom was typical you know
mexican mother tough love
um and it was the
career-wise not came easy but i was very
blessed and very fortunate
and uh i made up for the lack of
education
by just instincts and working really
[ __ ] hard
and just really and watching by you know
learning by watching and learning by
doing and
uh when i was on sets at a young age
what did you want to do how did you get
to a set
and also the people that are watching
like if you have a
if you haven't don't have a father you
don't have a parental or whatever that
doesn't mean you give up
no it just means that whatever you
decide to do is not going to be as
easy well it's not easy if you have both
parents nothing's easy nothing's
nothing's easy so don't think because
you know you
you're alone or you you drink and you
don't think you can stop or you have
this or
you've suffered loss that you can't get
up and continue and
be successful in whatever you want to do
there's a step that's why
there's steps and there's a [ __ ]
ladder to get to the top that you just
don't
elevate up or the bottom isn't the top
the bottom is the bottom
and to get to the top it takes steps
it doesn't then it doesn't happen
escalante said it best on ghana's you
can do anything
is that the truth and you go you go
through trial and tribulations as a
young child even as a young adult or an
older adult we all go through those
things even now so it's
you know it's just uh for me you know i
you know living in the vario living in
van nuys i was off with delano street on
van nuys boulevard
right there down the van i lived right
down there that was like a nice police
station that was heavy duty right there
right right it was right from where leno
right on delano street
14th street delano and vanessa boulevard
right down the street from the vantage
police department
and i was raised there are six kids
single mother grandmother who raised us
also
and it was tough there was not there's
not much to think outside the box our
our escape was television you know to
watch
you know i love lucy and all these
things and i i think subconsciously
that was my escape didn't ever know that
i would be in the business
uh played a lot of sports there was a
lot of community centers like the boys
club delaney street
so you played soccer and baseball so
kept us busy it kept us out of the gangs
and my mom was tough that way
and you know as we went along we all
started boxing so
boxing and i wasn't very good my brother
john john bray he was on the u.s olympic
team with oscar de la hoya
and shane mosley yeah yeah with that
name john bray yeah
john was was amazing he was number
number one in the world
uh for five years in the early 90s
number one in the united states number
two in the world for almost six years
and early 90s yeah it was amazing he was
on the u.s olympic team
and um and we just what did he do in the
olympics did he
no he he actually left he had some
issues he left and turned pro
and um he uh you know he had my dad's
disease you know he just
you love the alcohol bad choices is that
from your dad did i get that from your
dad
father i loved alcohol i loved yeah
i had a sister that uh loved alcohol to
death
yeah you know that's at age 47.
that's rough it's rough but he had a he
had a he had a great career as an
amateur
um he fought out everybody's camp
tyson's holy fields
he was smart holyfield when he was 17.
so
we all boxed and i was okay but it was
nice to have a good reference to my
little brother how what level you had to
be at so i knew that i
had to figure out what else i was going
to do and i was just lucky
i was training at at the at the jet
center which was on friar street vanna's
blinky yeah with blinky rodriguez benny
the jet
uh was never as big as bruce lee
but on the level on that level on that
level you would knock people out with
body shots he was
crazy
and blinky rodriguez actually yeah so i
which
i was training big japan up benny huge
huge
huge he had a weird round of face like a
yeah he was mixed he was mixed like
mexicano and japanese
uh and blinky was a badass too i think
he was a great fighter
great fighter and those dudes like ben
ukitas or blinky those guys out there if
you look them up
amazing fighters not a lot of attention
but in that time
warriors of chuck norris even and uh
super foot wallace and and they were all
like benny the jet is like
the guy and you'd see those guys coming
to the gym all the time so i just hit
the bag had a director
approached me asking auditioned for a
part i was i was 20.
and my little was that ron shelton
huh was that ronnie ron shelton was over
there ron shelton used to hang out at
the
jet center yeah at the jet center and he
did what tin cup and he did what movie
did you do what
else uh because ron shelton was a big
big writer big writer
director uh white man can't jump white
man ken
jump wow what's up didn't you do a
boxing one too he did a boxing movie
with uh antonio banderas
the one with sam the great white huh
play to the ball play it to the bone
play to the bone now that that's
hey that's mine that's what i do to the
bones
so i just you know i i i took advantage
of the opportunity and
and i met all these latino stunt men in
the business and
you know i worked two weeks on this
movie made more money than i ever
imagined and uh i just started learning
the business
on set learning how to drive cars and
high falls i was a stuntman for over 20
years and then the transition into stunt
coordinating and
and second to directing and then uh
specifically direct to secuna just for
joe carnahan and david o'russell
and then made the transition in
directing god what seven years
eight years ago and uh i done a couple
of episodes of television and then we
did el chicano together
yep that i wrote it was uh kind of uh do
you see el chicano
no you gotta see it you guys you guys
have to see kind of a mexican vigilante
superhero
it was it was it was a dedication to my
younger brother who passed away from
gang violence
and it was kind of uh the el chicano
theme was kind of a
um a metaphor of not having a father i
always felt if my dad was around maybe
he would have still lived
you know um chicago could be el chicano
could be
like daredevil yeah like the way that
the daredevil was like a show
exactly because he was protecting he's
protecting his community his value
coming back to the people i could
understand and they would yeah like
they would hear his motorcycle and they
would be you know god you know cholos
would be outside the house
and then you hear his motorcycle and
they'd just look up you know they go
[ __ ] this dude's gonna come over here
here he comes yeah
but it was a blessing and it's it's been
great i'm now doing a lot of television
and
uh a lot a lot of television so i feel
chicano
you started doing a lot a lot of
television i'm doing uh i'm i'm rob lowe
show
uh uh lone star i'm doing 9-1-1 next i'm
doing the new texas walker ranger series
that i'm directing uh who's texas who's
the texas walker ring i don't know who
the new actor is i literally just booked
it a couple of days ago
it's a new new actor it's the next
generation uh i do roswell i did uh
the last four seasons of queen of the
south and to be mexican-american
who was born and raised in los angeles
there's it's big it's crazy that there's
there's
no me there's only him yeah god bless
you yeah i feel very blessed
it's taking care of the food but also
but also
for people that want to do
how did you go you and you were in and
he was in um
lady gaga's movie oh uh yeah
[Music]
the parts i get are the parts where i
see other people and go man that could
have been me it could have been george
what's up
huh well you build these relationships
with actors when you're working as a
stunt coordinator so
i'd work with bradley cooper on silver
line's playbook and the a
team and so bradley was directing and he
gave me a call and said hey you want to
play his little part and you know get a
little scuffle in the bar and say yeah
man i'm actually home i could do it so
it was great
so it's always nice when you get those
calls did you see silver alliance
playbook
no all right i'm i didn't have time i
didn't have time for a bunch of movies
get some sprinklers they stopped
watering the [ __ ] grass all day he
just wants to get away
my grandfather used to water the grass
and i would say what the [ __ ] is he
doing out there
and then when i had my house and one
night i was out there and the sun
started going down and started watering
the grass like oh no
now i know why that's peaceful this [ __ ]
up yeah it's quiet
unfortunately my wife likes water
but you know especially with good with
good pressure
you know and i didn't want to water the
grass because if i was
if i was out in the backyard uh wetting
myself with the grat with the hose my
grandmother would throw
a [ __ ] bar zest out there take a
shower can you imagine man you're out
there having fun with your friends and
they throw a bar of soap at you
all right while you're out there
but this but yeah it's it's interesting
to see because
um there's not you're the only
mexican american television director
right now yeah
i mean you know there's got irito and
the guys from that are actually from
mexico
from here uh that are from born and born
in mexico but
mexican-american um right now that's
actually working
i i it's it's it's it's uh
it's unfortunate but yeah just right now
it's just me that's what started
this documentary when the guy first
approached me is because
and he was latino ryan gracia and he
said
we don't have he writes for he was
writing for chicago pd
he was writing for the mayans and he
says
we don't have a latino role model a
character he says you look
all the latinos are all villains yeah
you know they're bad they're dopers or
killers or this
he says but i've known you forever and
your story is good then it's
it's incredible that's it's time that we
have a latino and a positive role model
so that's what started all this you know
oh yeah
i i was i'm telling my the the wheels
were turning when i was watching i was
like this is a story that needs to be
told feature film wise
we don't have this it's it's there's two
sides to that street too it's
it's you have latinos and latinas
that you want just to play positive
roles whether it's a nurse a doctor a
lawyer not even
not even being specific about oh they
just they're just having to be latino
but they're playing that role who cares
whether they're mexican or not or puerto
rican or whatever they're playing those
roles
and they and that's a fight the second
part of that
is trying to just we have so many
[ __ ] stories
right just like tyler perry as we've
talked about this the picnics the
christmases the quinceaneras
the thanksgivings the comedy of those
that are latin based are you kidding me
we have a million stories about that and
amongst your story too
and and which is incredible for me i
always loved the human story the family
the familia
you know what what you i'm sure
it did it changed your whole life your
perspective and after after the
ramirez thing how you looked at things
how you dealt with you know
your own children your life and the
relationship build with your wife
it's a journey man that's what you go
back to marriage it's like it ain't easy
but you know
it's it's important things yeah i mean
that
that um if you look at richard ramirez
like
you know maybe the one of the most
successful donkey series
on netflix if you look at that and then
and then that guy
was compelling to people but all people
not not just to latino people but
but compelling and what made him
compelling that
was it just this i i think it showed
that
cops were human you know that we we have
we have a life we have a family
we have problems just like they do right
and
yet we still have a job you know and i
don't want to
mix anything up because it's in the news
right now but there's
one activist that was totally
police have to be held accountable he's
an activist against police officers
and his son just got tragically murdered
oh jesus and so now he's asking for help
he wants to solve it he says yes we need
to solve it
so here's a man that's been bad-mouthing
the cops and now he needs the cops to
help solve the son's murder
and and i'm not taking away from either
side of it but
that's a story in and of itself you know
what's gonna
and he says justice is justice
the bad cops i still say have to be
brought to justice the suspect in this
case has to be justice
as to meet justice and i don't think
there are too many people including cops
that would disagree with him
i certainly right want bad cops to be
handled and you don't go in to be a bad
cop no you don't
you know you're you you're not nobody
they're not above the law
that's right and and um he gives all the
good cops a bad name
right that's right so so what does
what does defund the police mean because
i think you hear defund the police and a
lot of people
may not know exactly what that means
like what does it mean when
when you hear people say in minneapolis
or new york or wherever
we have to defund the police some
they're saying
cut their funds and use the funds that
they're cutting from them
for social purposes to help those
get that money that we're spending on
the cops and wasting our tax dollars
and put them to the inner cities so
there's more to do for the
for the people that need it the kids on
the street
food work spend your money on
us don't spend it on cops because
they're not doing any good
what about what about because you know
think about this like the cop has to be
a psychiatrist he has to be a law
enforcement official he has to be a
psychiatrist
he has to be a a sounding board you know
they separate the man and the woman has
to be
a a a hero and he has to
be a fighter all in the chance that when
they roll up to a house or roll to a
building
they don't know what the [ __ ] is in
there they say hey some guy's out here
shooting somebody there's a guy here he
has his people here he has a person
hostage
he has this kid in there the kid might
be hurt
the guy might be have hurt his family
and a guy comes in a car or two guys or
a couple cars
and now look at i you know i have
things with the police i respect anybody
in authority
except people that i'm related to
but i can understand that but when you
roll up think about i mean think about
that
think about when you get rolled up and
the door's open and the guy's gone and
there's somebody in the street and
you're like okay
yeah yeah it's not just uh knock on the
door
this is it's bill here he's got you got
okay bill you got to come with me
it's all of that all these things are
going on and then you're [ __ ] human
you want to go home to your family too
yeah sure
and you don't know if that's this is
going to be the one time no man where
there were in in
l.a when they would call 9-1-1 and then
fire at the cops from
on top of buildings and should they kill
a couple police officers like that yeah
i remember telling a trainee
that he was just his partner asked me if
i'd swap with him for the night
so i he needed to go you just bought a
cab and i said sure
he said i got a trainee he says and the
guy's not the sharpest
knife in the drawer i said not a problem
i'll work with him
and he was latino and so he came and he
sat in a car and
he's nervous he's nervous man he said i
want i just want to do good i want to
get off training i want to be out here
and i said son two things we're gonna
accomplish tonight number one
we're gonna have fun if you can't have
fun then you're in the wrong job
[ __ ] and number two we're gonna go home
to our families at the end of the shift
that's all we got to do don't worry
about stressing yourself out can you
write this can you write
we're going to have fun and we're going
to go home
and if we can do that we're good i never
heard anybody say
we're going to have fun and we're going
to go home yeah because it was fun for
me out there i i did have fun
and and i enjoyed it and i never got
beef for just
being a dick or an [ __ ] or beating
the [ __ ] out of somebody
uh but i had fun i had fun i used to go
into a
there were a few bars on whittier
boulevard where on friday nights
all the latinos would go in there
they've got their money from
construction from wherever they were
and poveressa and all the guys going to
the mexican bars
and i'd go in there for bar check and
i'd walk in there and horale cabrones
and i'd look around and say hey
servatodos
and they start giving them beer and
bartender
la casa vapagar
these guys
before i became a cop i was driving for
three months for rtd
damn i didn't know that either see
really yeah i drove i drove for three
months
for rtd they when they when they called
me up they gave me they called me in to
give me a welcome aboard speech
hey you passed your probation you got it
you're the only trainee that has ever
been nominated for driver of the month
and hey
everything's going good for you and i
said well since you got me here let me
tell you
now i'll give you my two week notice
because i'm leaving for the department
wow
and they said well if it doesn't work
out the door swings both ways you're
welcome back
and i said well thank you very much but
i can remember i had the first street
26 line went from rowan and dozier in
east l.a up 1st street to broadway and
then out
uh to rimpau pico all the way to renpon
then turn around
well that was one that we're 24 hours
so at 1 30 in the morning i'm going down
1st street and all the burratus would
come out of the bars
oh [ __ ] and these guys would be hiding
their beer you know trying to get on
their eyes
just get on come on drink your beer back
there i didn't care
and i'm driving him well one time i some
guy got on and he was drunk
he drunk her in a [ __ ] house mouse and
he fell down and they got him they stood
him back up and now he starts cussing me
out
because he thought it was my bad driving
it but then we just couldn't hold on
good
yeah yeah so yeah
the guy the guy started yelling at me
the other people
i just pulled over at the next bus stop
they threw his ass out
i threw his ass out i closed the door
then everybody started cheering
well i think when you bring that kind of
attitude to a gig
to a gig like that like you you build
the people's trust in you
yeah yeah instead of being an [ __ ]
and leaving people
you're for the people and you're driving
and they sense that
you're a good dude you know that you
don't hey come on i see your beard come
on come on get on
get on somebody gets out of hand then
they're the ones saying
pull over i will throw this [ __ ] dude
off and they did and they got rid of
them
that ended my problem you know and even
when i was a street cop
or homicide if you got arrested if i
arrested you
if you had to be arrested you wanted to
go in my car yeah
yeah because we'd laugh we'd have fun i
i didn't i didn't care nothing that's
great this is just business
and i've had murder suspects i just
reminded the wife
uh the guy's name was dino p bradley
the guy got like he took he took his
partner to
court and made him late the judge locked
up his partner for being late
and i told the bail if i said run him
you know this guy's out there you know
dino p
bradley he was in a turquoise outfit
with turquoise curlers
and he had a warrant so run him
so he got him i said okay dino now
you're going with us brother
take your bag you got a warrant so we
took them back and we booked them i said
what does a p
stand for p is silent it don't stand for
a damn thing
[Laughter]
so i called up the wife and i said hey
i'm going to be a little late booking
some guy says hey i thought you just had
to go to court you're going to come out
straight from there
i said dear we ended up making an arrest
i'm going to be home a little late
i said you don't believe me i said hey
dino you want to talk to my old lady
he says yeah he picks he gets the phone
he says hello miss grillo
yeah me me and your husband we're going
to be home for dinner in a little while
and i said give me that damn phone
so she now was really booking somebody
so
well you know what they used his name as
a [ __ ] dinosaur character
[Laughter]
dino p bradley dino was a good guy too
he just
didn't pay his tickets he's always
getting in trouble yeah
he as we're coming down third street he
said just dump me off here i can make my
way home i said
these these mexicans will they'll kill
you
you know we don't have any uh blacks
living in this area he said
these backwood [ __ ] look at him
they had a hand
hand car wash there been there forever
on third street
he says even backward [ __ ]
don't even have machines to wash your
car
so yeah that's that's amazing man but i
think there's a story there right
there's a total story are you kidding me
all these stories because
i think that he was a bus driver should
not [ __ ] have that's a that's great
hey me and jackie gleason
to the moon pearl to the moon
you think about this like and i know you
you wanted to be a cop you you were
looking forward to that
what if the choice was you ended up just
being an rtd bus driver
made more money when i went to the
sheriff's office i took a pay cut from
driving the bus really
believable that's unbelievable
you're just talking about that and they
they told me i started at 842
a month for the with the sheriff's
department they said stay with us
i've been with them for three months
nine more months and you're eligible
we'll get you right into our because
they had their own police department at
the time
they had their own cops and their cops
started in a thousand dollars a month oh
man which was more money than i was
making here and plus they had overtime
they had all the
best benefits they had it made it was
good but
bus driving gave me nightmares you know
yeah yeah yeah that was the only thing
yeah well not because of the i was
afraid somebody's gonna hurt me
but with all the people complaining you
know hey hurry up i'm late hey slow down
you're going to kill us
get closer to the curb to make us jump
jesus christ why don't you get
why don't you get us a bridge to get
over there you know it was
it's too hot it's too cold just
constantly in your [ __ ] air
yeah so it was i didn't know that that
was the only time
i ever ever hit my wife
i was dreaming i was going for a parked
car and i kept turning that goddamn
wheel and
bottle i jerked it
i swear to god i was turning
[Laughter]
i think nationwide i think that um
police and high patrolmen and all the
troopers or whatever i
are at i think this country needs them
by the thousands
oh yeah yeah how how do we
because of everything that's going on
with the police how do we encourage
people
who are male i guess both male and
female people to
have a career in law enforcement
whenever you look at it you'll be like
[ __ ] that i ain't going in there it's a
tough road to hoe and i'll tell you
right now my grandson
who just had his 22nd birthday his dad's
a cop
and he said he was going to be a cop he
wanted to be a cop
and i said son once you be a fireman
instead people love everybody loves a
fireman nobody loves a cop
yeah yeah that's it that's it he said no
he said my dad's a cop he said i want to
be just like you papa
wow i said okay well you do it you can
do it on your own
and papa won't help you you got to do
this all on your own so he did it he
applied
uh when we found out he applied he let
the family know all he wants and there
was like geez he's really going through
this he wants to do it
started going through all of his tests
and he was passing everything
and then i hadn't heard anything about
what was going on
and i asked him we were out for our
anniversary day after christmas i asked
him
i said hey son you haven't heard from
the department uh
lately uh would you like me to check
into it for you see what's going on he
said nope
no so i got this i said okay you know i
stood out of it and let him go and
i told my wife when we left i said
he's got to change your heart or he's
been disqualified oh
something's something happened i said
nothing she said what do you mean i said
trust me you know yeah that was too
quick but no yeah
yeah so later on my wife tells me since
i talked to
renee his mom and she said that
he's known for a couple of months he had
a change of heart
but he was afraid and embarrassed
because he didn't want to disappoint you
wow and so i called the kid in the room
i said son you ain't never going to
disappoint me i think it's a wise
decision
have you talked to your dad he said yeah
my dad told me right away just don't
you know if that's bad time and i said
you're a good kid i love you i don't
care what you do and so
he had a change of heart and so many
people are going through that right now
uh it it it's going to take uh
people to take a different look at the
world you know right now that just says
maybe they're not all that bad i mean
they're human
people [ __ ] lie to you they don't
want to see you they don't want you
you're always a target
[ __ ] go by how do you how do you how
do you talk to somebody
that trying to talk him into being a cop
when everything they do is being viewed
they're in a fishbowl
tough time nobody likes you there is no
respect and everybody's going to talk
talk smack to you they they you see a
trend right now where people are going
into stores
and just taking anything they want
yeah brazen just doing that uh a very
dear friend of mine restaurateur
says at least two a night come in and
eat just get up there and i'm gonna
paint walk out
and so it's a tough time and
you know they're gonna give you lip
service a lot of lip service going on
and everybody's got
uh cameras now they're using body camera
which is good for the car i like body
cameras for the cops
so that people can see uh there's two
sides to every coin
but it's just a tough job to sell right
now to
uh young people out there what do what
do what do people do
store owners do restaurant owners do if
somebody comes in there
and starts to make them help themselves
to some stuff and want to walk out they
can't do anything
there's more civil liability security
cops are being told let them go
don't do anything because of the civil
liability to it then when you get to the
point where
in today's world today locally in
california
today where we have a district attorney
that is
minimizing everything so you arrest them
and they get a ticket to get out right
away they don't
you know here's a promise to appear just
like a traffic ticket
there's nothing to deter them they're
not going to spend even a weekend in
jail
right you know i had a local burglary
detective because
i was doing a live uh zoom with channel
and at the time they're doing it some
guys are coming they're running from the
cops they come to my gate
one guy's got a tire iron in his hand
the cops set up a perimeter
i mean this is going on right now i had
to tell channel
i got to go i got an emergency [ __ ]
it was it was real so they were this
happened at 702 in the evening
and at 10 30 that night they were
finally
the helicopter finally uh took off
closed down
guys got away and so
this was on a friday monday the burglary
detective comes over to my house hey
i want to see he's like i got him on
camera
you know hey let's you can see that sure
here it is that's what's going on
he says okay he says you know we're
gonna throw everything we can at it
uh but he said i'm gonna let you know
right now burglary is a felony
but i have burglars copping out yeah i
did that brother okay can you give me
tickets i can get out
oh jeez because there's no violence
involved yes
yeah she's given tickets for people to
get out under
the filing system the discretions of the
district attorney that we currently have
in office so
it's you might not that's the one that's
on recall you know
they got a recall petition going on on
them uh
george gascon uh there's at least 14
cities in the county in los angeles that
have submitted
their uh
what does that do guys is this people
also that
that that uh just before he got into
office
there were some protests and these
protesters had put a
uh a crossing over a railroad track
it could have possibly um
sometimes to try to derail the railroad
track and there was a big investigation
and as soon as he came they had they had
uh evidence
they have it actually on camera and then
when he went when he
when he was uh voted in uh he dismissed
the whole case
yeah he's uh yeah who is this dude man
he's
going he doesn't feel very much like an
l.a
he was with lapd before he left here
went up to
san francisco and
was the became the district attorney up
there
they weren't happy with them he's now
down here he filed with us
and we're here in l.a county and he's
changed socializing everything
uh no more gun and anthony you're 17
years old you kill five people
you still get out when you're 25 can't
file on you and his adult
jesus today a man got 35 years in prison
for killing his estranged wife in
southern california parole possible
because of george goscone directive
yeah yeah that's not uh has directed his
that's not when somebody comes up for
parole goscone has directed
his his representatives his
deputy district attorneys not to respond
and not to attend
parole hearings [ __ ] hey man how's
that possible how's that yeah
well he can uh he's
reduced enhancements so you go in you
commit a
you commit a homicide with a gun
you're an ex-con with a gun uh
the gun is stolen you shouldn't be
having a gun a sewing gun any gun so
there it is so all they're going to file
on you
is the murder charge no more
enhancements you know he's trying to
minimize wow
so there's a damn 14
cities right now have filed or had just
and it's
they're just saying it but it's a vote
or no confidence
has no weight on them but politically
they're letting everybody know
there's a vote or not he campaigned on
that campaign
he campaigned that he was going to
reform the system so what he's done is
he's
in his social realization he said
studies have shown that all this
incarceration doesn't do anything
uh what they need is to need to get out
and re uh
reassociate with their communities oh
and by another guy that's awful
because they're going and they're back
in the hood they're back doing their
thing and they're not afraid
they're that afraid that's the key
they've already done like the highest
crime
and they're [ __ ] there's nothing
exactly there's uh
word out that inmates are calling him
homie gascon
because he's [ __ ] letting him yeah
he's letting him out he's a homie
wow what a [ __ ] mess that is
that's not la right that doesn't feel
like an l.a was like
a hard d.a man like he was yeah
he was who was the heart id the guy that
looked like uh the guy from uh
spider-man the uh ira reiner did not
remember ryan chief from spider-man yeah
spider-man like a cartoon cut out he had
the white hair and the nose
you know he looked like like somebody
drew him yeah yeah
that's right well he was he was uh uh
how long were you chief
of in san fernando three months he was
the chief of police of saffron handle
no way yeah don't call me way but yes
anthony fourth of july they still sell
fireworks in san fernando yeah
[ __ ] burn your [ __ ] house down
they come and shake your hand the
firemen
wow was that just before you retired or
that was after i was it was 2012.
uh and he wore uniform and everything
yeah yeah
no no gun and ironically i kept a bullet
right here in my pocket
they uh coincidentally
uh the city councilman
a city council woman domestic violence
beat the [ __ ] out of her
councilman boyfriend and that's a
separator i know
and so i remember those everybody's
stealing calls from tom carroll
it was reported it was documented it was
photographed
and that happened on
thursday and
by tuesday they had a
council meeting and they went into
closed session
and wednesday they advised me that
because i wouldn't
let it go they wanted me they wanted i
wanted me to sweep it under the carpet
and i wouldn't do it and so
they said my services were no longer
needed they wanted him to go along with
this say hey man
just so it didn't happen it didn't
happen sorry yeah it didn't happen wow
and i told the city manager i said just
advise them that i take this
as a badge of honor you know i didn't
need i wasn't looking for a job when
they came to me they wanted me
i don't care the only person i feel
sorry for are the men and women that
have to stay working for them
when all the dust is settled the uh
local newspaper this what is it
uh they wrote an article in there and
said that at first they thought i was in
uh bed with the city council and they
now realize that i was the only man in
the city that
with integrity and so
uh and when everything was over
three council people were recalled city
attorney
and city manager were fired good and so
it was uh wow gail wow
i love the job i love the people i love
the cops great city i love the
city it's not that big i think there's
only like
111 people in san fernando just inside
the architect
there's not that many people i hate it i
hate it absolutely hated the drive
yeah where were you where are you
driving from san gabriel valley oh [ __ ]
that's the truth so it was uh and i
wouldn't get in the
if i was rolling hot if something was
going on i had to get down there
then i'd get in the car pool lane but
other than that i just stay in the
regular lane of traffic
like everybody else and it just changes
did you take a car home the police car
yeah i got i got the chief's car that's
what i was doing
so they didn't envy on the car pulling
the [ __ ] i have a thumb
you know you guys have a good day
[Laughter]
he's a man of integrity you meet very
few of those very few of them
very few it's a great story i mean man
has someone has someone have you written
you haven't written a book no one
nothing
i can't believe it it's shocking to me
hasn't seen silver linings play are you
ready are you ready to start are you
ready to start directing are you kidding
me yeah you just got right
right writing yeah let's do this i'm
telling you we got to talk we definitely
have to talk heard it right here
right here we get the point to go omg
i don't
[Laughter]
no i think something interesting i was
telling george already
i was excited i was ecstatic when you
told me you were going to be on
and already but the wheels are turned as
a director as a writer you always are
you're
always thinking it was like to see you
present day
as you're as the audience is seeing what
you're dealing with now
how you how you you uh how your life is
now
retired and having going back into
flashbacks
the younger you dealing with the case
dealing when you when you first started
the business
i mean listen man it's amazing
i mean vietnam was wow you hit i mean
there was no it's it what is it you
could come back you could not come back
you could be gone in a day you could be
gone in a month
you come back you're different you
changed i mean it's just
that's what my mother said when i came
back she she i came back and she started
telling me about
problems and i finally looked at her i
said mom
you don't have problems here mom you
have no idea they're little kids in
vietnam that are dying that
12 year old kids that are having we're
teaching them how to use guns to protect
their village
i said they've got problems you don't
have a problem then she started crying
you know and then it was it was tough
they have that but they
i mean yeah it changed kids didn't come
back you know a lot of kids that
i'm just came back we're happy you came
back i'm lucky man
and when he left beyond there was a
little bit little flat squash
squash right there right in the middle
of the village
they made a little soup out of it they
named that town after man
beef squash cambodia no i think it's a
great start i'd love to talk to you
about it and keep in touch with you and
uh and do this this is the he's amazing
hey for
between he and i we have the last 40
years covered in tv and
future 20 years ahead of time guys
you have you have uh george play you now
present time we get somebody younger
and we coincide we go back and forth i
think it's the best way to tell this
he's great
because he has integrity man like you
know chicago's man the people the guys
that were cops are going hey there's
the only one i know stole my bike while
[ __ ] don't leave it over there
if i was a cop and some kid said sir my
dad had my mom in a headlock behind your
mom i [ __ ] had like two children
i'll tell you where were you at
i'll tell you a story here
what's this for forget that fight oh get
my son please help my son who has the
biggest heart of anybody i know
so he he's about 19 years old and
i'm at work my wife picks him up he used
to be a work for a
a vans or some shoe sale shoe store
and she picks him up she says i'm gonna
stop right here i'm gonna go in smart
and finally buy something i'll be right
back
so he's in the car and she comes out and
he's gone
with the car and then he comes driving
up and she says
where'd you go he says oh mom says it
broke my heart i saw some transient
going through the garbage truck looking
for food
and i didn't have any money on me to buy
him all i had was my paycheck
and i couldn't stand to watch him so i
just drove away
and so my wife told me that that's
touching to a father
my son had a heart and so i went home i
said son i understand you saw something
today
and broke your heart he says yeah dad
there was this transient
and he tells me the story and it's very
touching i looked at him and i said
did he at least have shoe son and he
said yes i said well why don't you kick
his ass and steal him
i said come on son you got to take
advantage of everything
right yeah and so
he uh and he laughed you can't teach
that either
yeah he has it no yeah that's so it was
uh i just gave him a hug and i said
thank you for being you you know he's
he's just that's beautiful he's a good
kid that's beautiful
[ __ ] san fernando a triangle here
so yeah man thanks for coming isn't it
like that oh this is amazing
it's the most unpodcast podcast even
guilt comes back
unless he's late he doesn't take the the
the the
another beer too the hov wouldn't have
no i don't think
yeah i was supposed to
uh i was supposed to i did went down to
a place called schooner laters in long
beach right in the marina
and i found a once a week
i go to the vfw post so i'm gonna have a
couple of cocktails with the fellas that
yeah and served oh man
and one of the guys i see down there
occasionally we actually
flew together in vietnam
and the first time we found out and
he saw my wife my kids came out and we
were crying he said he told my wife you
don't understand
you don't understand why i'm crying he
says you see when we were in vietnam we
didn't even know if we're gonna make it
back
he says now not only did we make it back
but now i get to meet the family
amazing he says this is wow it's it's
amazing so
these guys going to the vfw this this
dude right here has
that's why there could be mr velvet
there he goes everything he can't even
write
some of these guys that i go that meet
me at the post the good bill cosby
[Laughter]
i'll put some pata in it
integrity man like that's what i'm
saying like you should go over to the
bfw see that guy like
so there's some guys there a couple of
guys that retired from the gas company
and those are the guy i go and i have
fun when we sit there
spend a couple hours with them then i'm
gone and they're the same way
so they've invited me and i've been
going to them now
you know other than during the pandemic
before then for over a year
they have a luncheon about every two
three months he's
get about 10 guys from the guy 10 to 15
guys from the gas company and they go to
different spots to eat
they invite me i go down there with
because it's just like sitting with
the guys from the block like sitting
with cops
they all make fun of each other they all
laugh they're all retired
and it's just a good time you know you
have to be a
veteran no no these guys there's only
two of us
two or three of us that are been in
service the other guys are just hanging
out how do we get in there
i don't know how do you get in there in
the bfw you go you tell me i'll
you're in okay there's another bfw
there's a bfw in every city
in san fernando is that different is it
yeah it's different they have bfw and
american legion
and american legions are anybody that
served in the armed forces
and the vfw's you had to have combat
here you were in combat so but we take
guests in there you don't have to be a
vietnamese probably empty them that
doesn't come by probably
dancing by himself
so today was the day we had lunch today
oh today
today was lunch by the time we got in
and then you had there's a half hour
wait this place is right on the marina
it's a nice place they serve good oh
really yeah it's called schooner laters
and they were uh
my my daughter's like are you back in
town they weren't
gonna tell her i'm just in the spirit
time of the bfw
so we went there and they all ordered
something to eat i couldn't even i
couldn't order anything to eat
because i wasn't gonna get by the time
the food got there i was gonna be able
to eat
to get over here to come down it was an
hour and two minutes that's what i said
on my thing an hour and two minutes to
get here yeah
and it took me just about an hour and
two minutes an hour and five minutes to
get down here
from the marina yeah yeah yeah so
uh there's gordo still hasn't had
anything to eat today
and you have to go eat or something yeah
yeah right
it's good what's the end how do i close
it i forget
thanks for tuning in everybody oh i
gotta lie is that it
it was awesome thanks for having me guys
you